i was taught uh
uh in a encryption and decryption
algorithm manual algorithm yep
you
you might be interested that eventually
i figured out
uh at least one of the patterns uh the
the algorithm was such that
the and this was all about digits like
uh and the algorithm was such that in
the end the
uh
the digits that were used to decipher
other digits that were handed that were
sent to me by a shortwave radio
there were let's say if there were a
hundred
digits there were an equal number of
ones twos threes fours fives six and
seven and up until zero
and i was told that
these
algorithms these manual algorithms were
good for about 300 uses after that they
could still be
deciphered i'm assuming nowadays that
wouldn't take as much yeah with
computers for sure but there's probably
they're probably designed in a way that
you can manually
sort of uh it's efficient and convenient
to use them manually well not to
optimize
cryptographic security is to optimize
it's like the balance security and like
humans being able to actually yeah no i
got to disagree it was neither efficient
nor convenient okay it took a long time
when what was what was significantly
easier to do
uh but
that would require you to have spy
paraphernalia with you do this is what's
called a one-time pad
so you have the set of numbers
on on a sheet of paper
that had to be developed i had to use
iodine to make those numbers visible
those
are known to be
unbreakable unless they are used
multiple times the same the same sheet
of paper
because you know the person who encrypts
has the same set of numbers as the
person who decrypts
and
one
one time use you cannot figure out what
the message is oh interesting but this
is a quick way to communicate from one
person to another one time one time well
one time but i had a pad with multiple
uh paper right and
the reason that they gave me a manual
one is because
i literally i had
only when i when i wound up in the
united states i had only one thing with
me
that uh
only a spy can have and that was a uh
a writing pad with uh
where the first 10 pages or so were
impregnated with a trace of a chemical
that was used for secret writing
uh but you really would have to know
what you're looking for to you know you
see this pad it was bought at a walmart
and can you explain a little a little
further what what is the chemical here
that
what are we talking about so how i i
don't understand how it's possible to
have a physical pad that does the
encryption without any computing
i how does it include right so so no no
it doesn't it doesn't do any work you
know so
and the uh the communication that the
encrypted communication was uh was a
set of uh
uh groups of five
five digits and then another five and
there's always a gap in between
uh and
so let's say if i get this radio
transmission i write them all down and
then i then i use my uh develop my
algorithm and then i do mathematics
either addition or subtraction
the resulting set of digits
had that then had a one-to-one
correlation to letters and this is an
easy way to then do the correlation yes
well that's cool that's uh you're saying
the algorithm was not efficient it was
not oh the manual it took a long time
and and
you can't make an arrow
right uh would you know where can you is
it easy to debug no you no you do it
twice
you do it twice and that's how you
change it's identical then you know
but like if it's not then then one is
right and the other is wrong don't make
mistakes no that's right and i really
didn't
you